en creuse les marionnettes descendent
dans la rue et cela va durer toute la
semaine dans les écoles à la mjc de
guéret à la souterraine et dans d'autres
communes du département 18 spectacles
sont présentés plus une exposition
permanente à guéret originaire de la
région de pau les auteurs de cette
animation appartiennent à plusieurs
troupes
la compagnie de l'échelle le vélo
théâtre l'imagier de l'ombre et le
théâtre de cuisine
aglaé poncet et gila rizzoli ont saisi
quelques-uns des moments drôles de ses
différents spectacles et scènes que vous
allez voir sont tournés francis tintori
connaissance et comme dit spectacle
qu'on a créé pour la rue et puis pour
les lieux un petit peu insolites comme
un bistrot comme une rue piétonne on a
même joué sous la scène d'un théâtre une
fois oui on devait jouer sur la scène et
la scène était complètement inadapté
alors on a été voir le directeur on lui
a dit il nous faut vraiment un petit
lieu le plus sombre possible est ce
qu'on peut jouer sous la selle dans le
trou du souffleur on a on pouvait mettre
50 personnes on a joué là il y avait des
toiles d'araignées c'était un ch'ti
formidable théâtre du quotidien c'est
l'un des spectacles proposés dans le
cadre de cette semaine d'autres lieux
sans abîmer les écoles les centres
culturels exemple la mjc de guéret où la
compagnie de l'échelle expose ses
marionnettes
quel est ce personnage c'est la misère
et son histoire
c'est une histoire très compliquée parce
d'abord il n'est pas tout seul il habite
avec deux autres marionnettes qui sont
juste derrière moi et quand clore les a
fabriqués il ya très très longtemps il
les a portés dans une caisse et il les a
déballé en 12 ans c'est la misère
on essaye d'éviter au maximum tout
spectacle au public homogène ce qui veut
dire par exemple que l'on prend 30
enfants de 8 ans c'est-à-dire
l'homogénéité c'est la tranche d'âge que
l'on amène au spectacle un peu con les
amènerait la visite médicale mais ça
nous on récuse
on essaye d'avoir d'autres rapports
qu'un rapport obligé avec le public
on essaye de faire en sorte que les gens
qui viennent au théâtre 4 les adultes et
les enfants le soir
mais que ce soit d'abord un geste
volontaire le théâtre c'est d'abord un
plaisir d'aller au théâtre
comment s'appelle-t-elle cette
marionnette
bof parce que il s'appelle bo font quand
ils se présentent il dit yu je m'appelle
bourse alors s'appelle bouffe parce que
ce que je suis pas le matin il s'est
fait avec un pétard puis assez bof
qu'est-ce qui va fort et on avait le
boeuf d'enfin c'est bof le gentil ça
c'est pas le boeuf profond aux formes
leurs thèmes favoris la solitude la
tendresse la beauté toute une collection
d'émotion et de rêves qui virevoltent
jusqu'à la fin de la semaine dans le
ciel creuser